ranking up in titanfall 2 is a lot
different than most of other games that
are being played and Call of Duty for
example you reach a certain amount of XP
you get to the next rank and then it
once you reach that much you rank up and
then you hit prestige Titan false a bit
different in the way that it ranks up
instead of using XP you you need merits
merits are these coins that you are
given after you rank up a certain weapon
gun character etc that is the way that
you need to rank up in titanfall and
that for the purpose of this video I
will be explaining how to rank up the
fastest using these merits now the first
thing you want to do is rank up your
guns and Titans as quick as you can
I tried to weigh the options between
taking one weapon in one Titan and power
leveling up that thing until I could say
rank 20 and then I did four different
weapons and slowly taking up their ranks
to rank five and I found out that doing
every single weapon slowly instead of
power leveling one certain weapon that
you like is a lot more beneficial
another thing that you might want to do
is doing challenges for your weapons and
Titans if you go to your gun if you go
to your weapon and Titan there's a skin
there's all the skins that you get for
your weapons and Titans each of them are
different and require different
challenges say some of them require you
to walk a certain amount of distance as
a pilot some of them require you to get
killing sprees get kills with as a Titan
get Titan kills etc these two these
challenges actually give you merit when
you complete them so doing as many
challenges as you can is more beneficial
to you ranking up in reaching gen 1 and
the last thing you want to do to rank up
your character is to play the objective
this is probably the most beneficial
thing you could do in titanfall 2 to
rank up the most
besides the weapons and besides the
challenges doing this is the most
important playing the objective a gives
your team a win which will get our
already give you 1x
merit for winning the game if you and
also if you do good in that game you'll
get another mayor for a good performance
but most of the weapons and Titans what
challenges require you to do a certain
amount of captures I defend a flag or
something like that and then you will
get kills and you will get these
challenges
once you complete these challenges you
will also be given a merit that is how
you rank up the most for titanfall - now
I know these are pretty simple and I
tried to make this video as quick as I
could
just small little details but if you did
enjoy like this video comment and if you
want more site and fall - and subscribe
peace guys